Je manque comme peu de souplesse.
C'est pas une mince affaire.
Depuis le temps que je m'habille
comme ça pour aller sur les parcs.
Je commence à avoir un peu l'habitude.
Passe devant.
Les parcs à huîtres du bassin d'Arcachon,
le jardin de Dominique Aloir.
À 70 ans, toute une vie
rythmée par les marées.
En face de la dune du Pilat,
le banc d'Arguin.
J'adore revenir ici,
C'est naturel, c'est merveilleux !
Je ne veux pas être chauvin,
mais je trouve l'endroit magnifique.
C'est un site merveilleux.
D'ailleurs, l'été, les plaisanciers ne
se trompent pas, ils viennent au banc d'Arguin.
J'apprécie le banc d'Arguin
quand il n'y a personne.
C'est un joli bureau. Exactement.
On va essayer de passer par là.
Ça doit être plus profond.
Je vais descendre là parce que...
Là, il y a un banc de sable.
Ça y est, on l'a passé.
On regagne un peu d'eau là.
Quand il n'y a pas beaucoup d'eau
qu'on ne peut pas lancer le moteur,
On se déplace à la barre.
Ça, c'est un mât de planche à voile.
Avant, c'était des barres en pin,
des petits pins.
Ça, c'est mon paradis.
On est bien.
C'est beau, il n'y a pas un chat.
C'est bien.
Moi je trouve ça très...
C'est super.
C'est joli comme huitre ?
Ça pousse, Nico.
Ça a l'air de mieux pousser ici.
Ce sont des huîtres qu'on
va vendre cet été.
C'est pour cet été.
On viendra les chercher
la semaine prochaine.
Une huître, c'est trois ans de travail.
Moi, j'aime faire de la qualité.
Je fais de la qualité,
Parce que quand je vends une
douzaine d'huîtres à un client,
Ce que j'aime, c'est qu'il revienne.
Quand je vois un client qui revient,
je me dis,
Je l'ai bien servi et je lui
ai donné de la qualité.
J'ai pas une vie ambitieuse
mais c'est ma vie.
J'aime ce que je fais, c'est le principal.
Le matin, quand je me lève,
je suis content d'aller embaucher.
Les huîtres embarquées,
en 20 minutes de bateau,
Dominique rentre chez lui,
dans sa cabane.
Sur le pouce, tout juste sorti des parcs,
Des huîtres à volonté.
Dès qu'on a du soleil, on a du monde.
Nous, on travaille très bien.
Je suis content.
Ici, la région jusqu'au 30 août,
c'est bien.
Au milieu des tables, le vivier.
Là, c'est le garde manger.
Les huit trucs que nous allons
chercher au parc pour la vente,
on les calibre, on les lave, on les
met là, et on les vend au fur et à mesure.
L'été, on va en chercher tous les deux jours.
Passionné par son métier,
Dominique est fier de ses huîtres.
Ça, c'est une huître
qui est née dans le bassin.
Des huîtres, j'en mange tous les soirs.
L'hiver, c'est mon repas du soir.
Je fais les huîtres depuis l'âge de 16 ans.
Je n'ose pas dire combien ça fait...
Ça fait 54 ans que je fais le métier.
Et c'est vrai que j'ai fait
ce métier avec passion.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi,
j'ai adoré ce métier.
Au départ j'aime la nature,
On est dans la nature, on est sur les parcs,
je respire, je suis bien sur les parcs !
Surtout l'été, le matin
de bonheur, c'est super.
Dans la famille Aloir, les huîtres,
c'est toute une histoire.
Vous vous en sortez ?
Stephanie, la fille de Dominique,
va poursuivre l'aventure.
- La relève, elle est assurée ?
- Voilà, la relève est ici.
Elle veut faire ça.
Alors ça fait que je ne peux
pas encore prendre la retraite,
Mais j'en suis ravie.
Et ce métier ça ne vous fait pas
un petit peu peur ?
- Sur la dureté du truc ?
- Pas du tout.
Commercialement, elle se débrouille très bien.
Le contact avec les clients, tout ça...
Je ne sais pas à quelle table.
Douze petites crevettes, bulots,
palourdes et un demi blanc ?
- C'est ça.
- Alors 38,50€.
Moi, je suis née ici, mes grands parents
étaient ostréiculteurs.
C'est une vie, c'est ma vie.
Et puis cet endroit, on ne va pas
le laisser quand même.
C'est surtout pour l'endroit
aussi qu'on est là.
On serait dans un port où ce
serait moins joli ou moins sympa,
Oui, peut-être que je n'aurais pas repris.
Là, nickel. La vie est belle.
Papa, oui, c'est une figure.
Il est toujours là, il ne bouge pas.
Et puis il sera là jusqu'au bout, je crois.
Je ne vais pas m'en débarrasser de suite.
J'essaye, mais ça ne marche pas bien.
Il fait exprès pour nous stresser.
À L'Aiguillon, Dominique
est le dernier ostréiculteur.
Les autres cabanes de ce quartier d'Arcachon
ont fermé les unes après les autres.
Ce sont des ostréiculteurs qui
ont arrêté il y a 6 ans,
Qui faisaient la pêche et l'ostréiculture.
J'ai fait le métier d'un homme.
C'était la seule femme
parce qu'il fallait être 2.
Il fallait tirer d'un côté, de l'autre.
Et là, vous revenez par quoi ?
C'est par nostalgie ?
On ne peut pas s'en passer.
Non, on ne peut pas
s'en passer, de venir.
C'est le paradis.
On mange, on est tranquille, on
respire la santé, vous voyez pas ?
Et là, aujourd'hui, on se rend compte
qu'en fait, Dominique, c'est le dernier.
Il est tout seul.
Le dernier des Mohicans.
C'est vrai que toutes les cabanes
que j'ai connu,
C'était que des ostréiculteurs, c'est vrai.
L'été, la cabane de Dominique
ne désemplit pas.
Le service est assuré midi et soir.
À quelques kilomètres
de la cabane de Dominique,
Le port de Gujan-Mestras.
À 36 ans, Gregory Debord est
à la tête d'un chantier naval.
Sa spécialité : la pinasse.
Le bateau du bassin.
Le début de l'été, pas vraiment des vacances.
Les pinasses doivent être livrées
pour les beaux jours.
Dans 15 jours, 3 semaines. Il faut qu'on
soit au bout des différentes réalisations.
C'est le dernier feu de l'action.
On est au bout.
On devrait d'ici une semaine
arriver à l'aboutissement,
On fini les vernis,
ils vont avoir une autre figure.
Charpentiers de marine de formation.
Gregory s'est lancé dans
l'aventure il y a six ans.
Aujourd'hui, sept personnes
travaillent pour lui.
Thomas, c'est marrant parce qu'en fait
il faisait les cercueils avant.
Et il s'est mis à la pinasse.
Il est de Saint-Etienne, il n'est pas ici.
Il n'y a pas de bateau chez lui.
Donc en fait, là, on a la pinasse
traditionnelle, mais moderne en même temps,
puisqu'on a tous l'aspect finition bois,
Et la coque en polyester et d'autres
petits aménagements dedans en polyester.
Quand les premières pinasses ont
été motorisées pour qu'elles soient à plat,
Qu'elles flottent dans moins d'eau,
Il y en a un qui a a fait une hélice
relevable par un système de crémaillère,
Donc il y a des crans dedans,
on a trois positions.
Bas, milieu, haut.
Au milieu haut, tout est aligné,
donc ça fait que le bateau peut passer
dans n'importe quel fonds,
Et l'hélice se continue quand même
à tourner sans aucun problème,
Et peut propulser la pinasse. C'est quelque
chose qui est complètement adapté au bassin,
Et à tout plan d'eau,
Où le phénomène de marée est important.
En ce mois de juillet,
Gregory est sur tous les fronts.
T'as mis de l'essence ?
Tous ces bateaux là, ils sont accrochés
à ce qu'on appelle un corps-mort.
C'est un poids au fond de l'eau qui les tiens.
Là, on a eu le numéro et l'emplacement
pour mettre en place le corps-mort,
D'une nouvelle pinasse qu'on construit.
Donc en fait, on vient préparer
la mise à l'eau des corps-morts.
Non, pas si gros que ça.
Juste comme ça.
T'as vu ? Comme les magiciens !
J'ai fait un nœud, il n'y a plus rien !
Alors là, attention les pieds.
Attention à tes jambes.
C'est bon ?
C'est la bonne ?
C'est bon, ça y est, oui.
Sur le bassin d'Arcachon,
la pinasse, plus qu'un bateau,
c'est une tradition.
C'est un patrimoine auquel
sont beaucoup attachés les gens.
D'ailleurs, historiquement, les pinasses
avaient la couleur de la maison,
Parce que c'était avec la peinture
de la maison qu'ils peignaient le bateau.
Donc il y avait souvent une cohérence de
couleurs entre la maison et le bateau.
Et c'est le dernier bateau dont
les gens ont du mal à se séparer.
C'est vraiment le bateau auquel
ils restent attachés longtemps,
Et même dans les séparations de bien
où souvent le bateau n'est pas vendu.
Patrimoine familial.
Oui, patrimoine familial important.
C'est un repère en fait, la pinasse.
Je mange pinasse, je bois pinasse.
En face de la ville d'Arcachon,
les plages du Cap Ferret.
Une bande de terre
entre l'océan et le bassin.
À côté du débarcadère,
les pieds dans l'eau,
Le restaurant de Laurent et Alexandra.
- Bonjour Monsieur.
- Pour deux personnes.
Sans réservation je vais avoir
uniquement ces deux petites tables là.
Voilà, c'est tout ce que j'ai, monsieur.
Tout est complet.
L'été, la terrasse est prise d'assaut.
14h30.
14h30, ça vous va ? Très bien.
C'est noté. À tout à l'heure.
La salle est déjà pleine sur réservation.
Notre but, c'est d'arriver à gérer
le deuxième service qui arrive derrière,
Où il faut avoir les tables à 14h,
ne pas faire trop attendre les gens.
- Vous faites du coloriage ?
- Elle adore.
En ce moment, c'est ma spécialité,
j'allais dire.
Le Cap-Ferret c'est
une clientèle d'habitués.
Essentiellement, c'est des familles qu'on
connaît depuis toujours quasiment.
Donc c'est vrai que c'est toujours
un casse-tête pour bien placer les gens,
Le mieux possible, éviter de refuser.
Pour sa cuisine, Laurent s'est offert les
services d'un ancien chef étoilé.
Pascal Nibaudeau.
Oui, ça démarre, ça va aller.
Il y a du monde, il y a surtout
beaucoup de monde au deuxième.
Des grosses tables.
Deux fois dix, deux fois huit.
Et pas mal de monde encore.
Bon courage.
En haute saison, le chef doit assurer
jusqu'à 600 couverts par jour.
Attention à vos sauces là !
Au fait Jeannot, va falloir
qu'on en parle de notre sauce.
Voyez les turbot et un poisson qu'on retrouve
beaucoup dans le bassin maintenant,
C'est la tombe.
Vas-y toi.
Moi je sais faire !
Allez, ça part !
Fais attention à la marche.
Faute de place en terrasses,
Laurent installe ses clients à l'intérieur.
Le restaurant s'est construit autour
d'une vieille maison achetée par son père.
Voilà, je vous souhaite un bon appétit.
Ça, c'est la maison originelle.
1890, aux alentours.
Une des premières villas du Cap-Ferret.
Là, il y a la toute première
photos de ces années là.
Là, on avait récupéré la maison
qui était dans son jus.
Où on commençait à peindre
les premières tables.
Ça, c'était donc 89 et on a continué
l'aventure avec ma femme Alexandra depuis.
Donc on a posé des pierres petit à petit,
là où nous nous trouvons,
Avant, c'était la cuisine initiale.
La maison n'a pas vraiment bougé.
Les cloisons sont restées là.
Le couloir, les chambres,
la cuisine de l'autre côté.
On a gardé l'esprit, mais on a transformé
en restaurant pour des raisons commerciales.
Mais l'esprit de la maison est
quand même resté là, présent.
À l'approche du 15 août, le bassin d'Arcachon
s'apprête à vivre l'événement de l'été.
Une fête qui rassemble
tous les habitants du bassin.
Le 15 août à Arcachon,
les fêtes de la mer.
Une procession en hommage
à la Vierge Marie.
La journée des amoureux du bassin.
Un défilé de centaines de bateaux,
Bénis tour à tour
par l'évêque de Bordeaux.
Bonne régate !
Pour mettre un peu d'ordre,
la police du bassin.
La brigade nautique de la gendarmerie,
avec Titi à la barre.
Le 15 Août, les fêtes de la mer,
C'est le jour de la festivité du Bassin,
c'est vraiment la journée la plus importante,
Où il y a énormément de bateaux qui sortent
et vous voyez, c'est bon enfant.
C'est tout amusant même pour nous.
C'est là que l'on voit qu'on est
aimé par les gens de la mer,
puisqu'ils prennent plaisir
à venir nous arroser.
Et ils savent surtout qu'ils
ne craignent pas grand chose !
Ils savent très bien que le premier souci,
nous ici, c'est de leur porter secours.
Et après mettre en place la réglementation.
Et vous vous faites
arroser même en service ?
Voilà, même en service, on se fait arroser.
On décale et c'est après la bouée.
C'est un petit peu...
Le départ est pas mal,
Mais après c'est au niveau organisation,
c'est un petit peu le cirque.
Même s'il y a quelques tolérances, faut
faire attention quand même au petit débordement.
On a un jet ski qui est là pour nous aider,
Qui est beaucoup plus mobile.
Dis-lui qu'il avance un peu devant nous,
Parce que là vous êtes en train de bloquer,
ça ne va pas le faire au virage.
Allô !
Faut refaire le tour ! Vous êtes
en train de me donner un mauvais sens là !
Regardez ! Mais non !
Faut faire le tour des bouées !
Pas possible ça !
Après la vedette gendarmerie,
vous pourrez virer.
À la nuit tombée, changement d'équipage pour
sécuriser le traditionnel feu d'artifice.
Ce soir, le major Gazengel est de service.
L'idée, c'est faire respecter
le périmètre de 160 mètres,
Autour du point de tir de la jetée.
Empêche-le de rentrer.
Vous vous écartez, s'il vous plaît.
Vous vous écartez vers le large.
Bonsoir la gendarmerie, même chose,
vous êtes dans l'axe du vent.
Et vous êtes en limite de périmètre, on va vous
demander d'avancer d'une vingtaine de mètres.
Vous avez votre échelle
en plus qui est rabattue,
Je vous le dis pour info, vous allez
vous l'arracher, je vous en prie.
C'est un joli 15 août,
il manque juste quelques degrés.
Normalement, on est en tee shirt au 15 août.
Cette année, on est un peu en
dessous de ce qu'on a l'habitude,
mais sinon, la soirée
se passe bien en tout cas.
Bouquet final
et bientôt fin de l'été.
L'effervescence de la haute saison passée,
Arcachon va bientôt retrouver son calme
et ses couleurs de l'automne.
En ce début du mois d'octobre,
après avoir navigué tout l'été,
Les bateaux de Gregory
doivent être mis à l'abri.
Là, on vient récupérer cette pinasse
qui a passé la saison à naviguer.
Maintenant, il faut qu'elle rentre en garage,
Pour préparer la saison d'après
et puis l'hiver va bientôt arriver là,
Même si on a une météo extraordinaire,
On va vite avoir les gels qui
vont arriver en suivant,
Et pour éviter d'abîmer les vernis,
on les rentre avant.
Grégory construit les pinasse,
il en loue aussi.
Un petit mot du client.
Merci pour la saison
et qu'il est retourné à Paris.
Mais moi j'y retourne pas à Paris.
Je reste là, c'est sûr !
Non, je mens, je vais à Paris
voir les matchs de rugby.
Et c'est tout !
Là, on va récupérer un autre
bateau sur un autre ponton,
Pour ramener les deux
bateaux en même temps.
Vu qu'on a une météo clémente
et une mer sympa,
on va prendre un bateau
en remorque de l'autre.
Il fait un peu chaud là.
Le problème de l'été indien, c'est ça !
Bon, allez, go !
Là, ils sont à fond à la pêche.
Là, ils pêchent à fond et là-bas aussi,
On voit toutes les mouettes
qui volent au dessus.
Alors là, t'as bien compris
qu'il y a du poisson !
Pour que ça chasse autant si près de l'eau...
C'est la meilleure période pour les
retraités et pour ceux qui ont du temps.
Retraités, RTT.
Et nous, on n'a même pas le temps
de pêcher. On passe à côté.
Mais c'est pas grave.
Regarde, on les voit juste
au ras de l'eau en plus.
À L'Aiguillon, chez Dominique,
l'ostréiculteur, c'est marée basse.
Ça me fait un peu bizarre
de plus voir personne.
Mais c'est comme ça, toute façon,
il faut une fin.
Là, on pouvait plus continuer.
C'est vrai, ça me fait un peu
râler parce qu'il fait beau,
Il y a du monde qui vient
pour déguster et on est fermé.
Je les envoie chez les collègues.
Pas de vacances pour Dominique,
le pic de l'été à peine passé,
se profile déjà la course de Noël.
Il faut qu'avant noël, tout soit prêt.
Ça n'arrête jamais ?
Non, ça n'arrête jamais.
Mais c'est vrai !
On a mis tout le monde
en vacances parce que,
Je leur dois des vacances quand même.
Et moi, je profite des vacances pour refaire
toutes ces petites bricoles.
Ça sert à ça les vacances.
Vous partez jamais du bassin ?
Non, je suis bien ici.
Je ne suis pas loin de mes huîtres.
J'ai du mal à m'en défaire.
Ça m'inquiète un peu quand même.
Je voudrais me défaire quand même...
C'est comme ça, c'est la vie.
Moi, je suis heureux ici.
On finit ça.
Il va falloir laisser sécher et on va aller
se faire une petite partie de pêche.
On va aller aux casserons.
Les casserons, de petites
seiches que Dominique,
Va aller pêcher avec
son ami d'enfance, Jacky.
Et il faut inscrire les trucs ?
Non, on va les mette ça va aller.
Faut surtout pas oublier à boire.
P**** ! Tu te prends ça sur le cou...
Comment il s'appelle ton bateau ?
Le bateau ? Aramis.
C'est un descendants de d'Artagnan.
Comment tu l'écris ?
Où on peut mettre ça ?
Dominique, il fait beau,
les flics sont à l'apéro,
On met les deux filets.
Allez ! On se mouille.
C'est le cas de le dire !
Je n'ai rien préparé,
j'ai pas eu le temps.
On n'a pas eu le temps,
on est à la retraite,
On n'a pas eu le temps
de préparer les filets.
C'est quand même incroyable ça !
On se met entre les 2.
Oui mais on va poser
la parallèle au parc.
D'accord je me rapproche.
Voilà les oies bernaches.
D'habitude elles arrivent
au mois de novembre.
L'oie bernache, c'est un
oiseau qui passe l'hiver,
Sur toute la côte atlantique,
on en a beaucoup sur le bassin,
C'est bon ?
Recule.
Doucement.
Il encercle bien l'annexe.
C'est bon Jacky, je mouille tout.
Quand il y a des casserons
et des petits rougets,
Tous les gens du bassin vont
à la pêche aux casserons.
C'est marrant !
Là, on va les pêcher au filet,
Et là maintenant,
on va pêcher à la ligne,
À la turlutte.
C'est un leurre et c'est vrai que ça fait
marrant quand on dit qu'on pêche à la turlutte.
15€ les 10 turluttes !
Il y en a ?
Oui, c'est du bon !
Bon, maintenant c'est du sérieux.
Oui, parce qu'elles attendent
que ça se découvre.
Ça c'est la turlutte, mais
la turlutte qui pique !
Regarde !
Tu peux la mettre derrière.
- Ça, c'est une sèche.
- Un casseron.
Dominique, on fait ça
et là elle ne crâche pas.
J'en ai une, je crois.
M**** !
Regarde !
C'est malin ces cons.
Il faut faire attention parce que ça gicle !
Il y a un peu de poisson,
il y a quelques rougets.
Je ne vois pas de casserons,
Ça c'est bon, le rouget-barbet.
Le vrai rouget.
Ce qu'on appelle le vendangeur.
On a le repas !
Le repas est à bord.
La pêche est à bord.
Un des rares moments
de détente pour Dominique.
En attendant l'hiver
et la frénésie du réveillon.
Au Cap-Ferret, la foule a déserté les lieux,
Mais Laurent et Alexandra se projettent
déjà sur l'été à venir.
On y accède par ici avec
une petite échelle, par là,
Ou il faut voir et on y accédera ici,
donc la toiture sera
interrompue ici et ici,
Pour avoir cet espace libre ici
et pour pouvoir envoyer...
Ils se lancent dans d'importants travaux.
À l'arrière du restaurant,
ils veulent créer un nouvel espace,
Et tout doit être prêt
pour la belle saison.
Il faudrait que la cuisine, le bar,
l'aspect commercial soient terminés,
On va viser le premier et on va
livrer le huit comme la dernière fois !
On doit être prêt pour
début avril, donc ça,
C'est l'impératif parce qu'il ne
faut pas qu'on rate la saison d'après.
c'est un peu comme dans le prêt à porter,
on a toujours une saison d'avance.
On vend l'hiver, l'été et l'été l'hiver.
Ce sera prêt pour l'été prochain ?
Bien sûr !
Mais bien sûr !
Laurent et Alexandra ont
une autre idée en tête,
Assurer la promotion d'un produit local.
Sur le bassin, l'automne,
c'est la saison du caviar.
Le moment où les esturgeons
portent le plus d'œufs.
Les premiers poissons qu'on a vu là-bas,
sur les bassins, c'est quel âge ?
La logique, c'est plus on avance
vers la station de traitement,
plus on est en présence d'animaux âgés.
Donc là, on est sur des 1, 2, 3 ans.
Et là, on est plutôt sur des 5, 6, 7.
Là, on est d'accord,
ce sont que des femelles ?
Ce sont que des femelles.
À partir de trois ans, on élimine
les mâles qui partent à la découpe.
Je suis impressionné par l'installation,
parce que c'est gigantesque.
Le travail, la complexité.
C'est un vrai métier technique,
Et qui nécessite beaucoup de savoir-faire
et beaucoup d'expérience.
On parle beaucoup du vin, mais on peut
parler maintenant du caviar aussi.
7 à 8 ans d'élevage avant que les femelles
ne soient vidées de leurs oeufs.
Ici, précaution maximale,
La moindre bactérie peut
ruiner toute la production.
C'est des jolies femelles.
Elles ont environ 7 ans.
Elles sont dans les plus jeunes.
Donc là, elles viennent de sortir du bassin.
On les a assommé,
saigné pour éviter qu'il y ait
du sang dans les gonades.
Là, il va les ouvrir.
Il va les retourner pour
qu'on puisse voir les oeufs.
On prélève un petit peu.
7.
Nouveau lot de dix, marron clair.
Huit.
Et huit aussi.
Plus un grain va être gros,
plus il va être intense en goût.
Voilà, là, c'est la matière première.
Ça c'est superbe.
Il y a à peu près 500 grammes.
500, 600 grammes.
Et ça vaut ?
Ça vaut autour de 1000€.
Emmanuelle, vous pourrez
laver le premier lot.
Une fois qu'on a tamisé tout le lot,
On passe au lavage.
Donc c'est ce que va faire Emmanuel,
Qui va nous permettre d'enlever
tous les petits bouts de gras,
Et une fois que le lot va être
fini de laver, on va les goûter,
Et en fonction de la texture,
on va le saler.
Et on met en petite boîte.
Donc une fois qu'on a
fait rentrer les oeufs,
C'est parti directement dans  les petites
boîtes qui sont pesées après au gramme près.
Étiquetées pour garder toute
la traçabilité et fermer sous vide.
Vous êtes fier de ce caviar d'Aquitaine ?
Oui.
Une boîte de 100 grammes vendue 200€.
De l'or noir que Laurent et Alexandra
cherchent à mettre en valeur.
Ce soir là, au restaurant du Cap Ferret,
c'est dégustation.
Pour l'occasion, Nikolaï,
un chef russe, a été convié.
Pour communiquer avec Nikolaï ?
Ce n'est pas facile.
Ça n'a pas été facile. Au début,
on a un petit peu chipoté,
Alors moi, en plus, j'étais un peu stressé
puis finalement, tout s'est passé très bien.
Nikolaï a fait tout ce qu'il avait à faire.
Finalement, il a produit, j'ai donné
ça à mes gars, puis ça s'est fait.
Voilà, des fois on communique
comme ça, regardez.
Des fois on communique comme ça.
Il écrit, il traduit et il me dit :
"Tiens, regarde".
Nikolaï.
Sur le bassin d'Arcachon,
L'été indien finit par s'achever.
Bientôt, les frimas de l'hiver.
C'est par ici les marrons.
Dans quelques jours, c'est Noël.
Sortie en famille pour Gregory,
le constructeur de pinasse,
Avec ses trois enfants
et sa femme, Vanessa.
Allez, tu ne veux pas des marrons ?
Moi, j'en veux.
Non, barbe à papa,
C'est un truc de fête foraine.
Arcachon, à Noël, c'est pas mal ?
C'est pas pareil, c'est fabuleux.
C'est pas Paris et ses embouteillages !
Non, il fait bon y vivre.
On a l'eau, la mer, la forêt.
On a tout ce qu'il faut.
Et Grégory l'hiver, les commandes,
c'est un peu plus cool ?
Oui, c'est la période plus cool.
Les vacances de Noël, c'est fermé,
donc du coup, on se pose en famille.
De la glace sur du sable.
Tu n'as pas le droit Esteban, viens ici.
Super, on patine avec vue sur le bassin,
Avec un soleil de saison.
Noël sur le bassin, oui,
c'est de plus en plus actif.
Plutôt l'ostréiculture qui est en pleine
effervescence pour les huîtres,
C'est le repas de Noël bientôt.
- Ça va Lolo ?
- T'es bien là ?
Noël est dans deux jours,
Dominique n'a plus
le temps d'aller à la pêche.
Voilà, les huîtres du réveillon.
Les huîtres de Dominique vont bientôt être
expédiées dans la France entière.
Là, on les lave.
Et c'est prêt pour la vente.
Il faut que ce soit propre une huître.
Quand on ouvre une huître, s'il y a de
la vase au dessus, ce n'est pas plaisant,
Il faut que ce soit nickel.
Moi, je le vois comme ça.
En cette période de fêtes,
toute la famille est réquisitionnée.
Stéphanie, la future patronne,
est à la baguette.
Alors ces caisses, elles partent
dans toute la France,
Elles partent, elles arrivent en 24h,
Donc ça part,
deux tonnes dans toute la France.
C'est la journée la plus stressante.
Faut que ça parte à l'heure
et dans de bonnes conditions.
Qui est prêt là ?
Toi, Sébastien ?
C'est vrai que moi ça me stresse.
C'est mon tempérament qui est comme ça,
j'aime que ce soit bien fait.
J'espère que les gens seront contents.
Il t'en reste deux.
Elle se débrouille bien, mais
je viendrai de temps en temps,
me faire engueuler parce qu'elle
m'engueule un peu quand même !
Livraisons mais aussi vente à emporter.
À la boutique, Claude, la femme
de Dominique, est venue en renfort.
Trois et quatre.
Trois et quatre, 44,10€.
Voilà, on peut en goûter une ?
Maintenant ?
Le couteau doit être par là, vous l'ouvrez !
- Il est où ?
- Par là, vous le cherchez.
Apportez-moi le code.
C'est une des meilleures ventes aujourd'hui ?
C'est pas mal.
Pas plus que ça ?
Mais non, ce sera mieux mercredi.
- Le jour J.
- Oui.
Et qu'est-ce qu'il se vend le mieux ?
Les moyennes toujours.
Puis les plâtres.
On a commencé à vendre des plates.
Ça, c'est mon amoureux.
Petit n'oublie pas tes huîtres.
L'important, c'est d'avoir payé.
- T'avais pas un chien ?
- Il est dans la voiture.
Le rhume est passé?
Oui, j'ai encore un petit
peu la goutte au nez.
Ça, c'est les années ça.
Dans la grisaille de l'hiver,
de l'autre côté du bassin,
Plus un chat sur la terrasse du
restaurant de Laurent et d'Alexandra.
Tout se passe derrière.
Le restaurant est en plein chantier,
Laurent veut s'assurer
de l'avancée des travaux.
Est-ce qu'on peut passer par là ?
Non, on ne passe pas par là.
Alors, on va aller voir ça.
Bonjour monsieur.
Il y a de la matière qui arrive.
Il y a le plancher du premier étage,
donc il va y avoir les cuisines ici,
Et ensuite la terrasse qui va donner sur
le passage des gens qui arrivent d'Arcachon,
Et qui vont prendre le petit train
pour aller à l'océan et qui, j'espère,
S'arrêteront pour manger un peu sur le pouce,
Déguster un petit burger ou des petits
tartares ou des choses comme ça.
Même au cœur de l'hiver,
le restaurant reste ouvert.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez
boire les petits lou ?
Mais l'ambiance est plus familiale.
Les clients, pour l'essentiel, des locaux.
Je croyais qu'il était parti.
Les trois vont chez Maurice.
D'accord, ils vont chez Maurice.
À la votre !
À la vôtre, profitez bien.
Passez un agréable moment.
Voilà, c'est l'hiver, on y est.
C'est ce que j'aime bien ici, c'est
qu'on vit vraiment au rythme des saisons,
le tumulte de l'été,
la renaissance du printemps,
Et aussi la tranquillité de l'hiver.
La tranquillité de l'hiver,
pas pour tout le monde.
La brigade nautique
est sur le pied de guerre.
À titre d'info t'as croisé de
l'ostréiculture sur Arguin ?
Pas d'ostréiculture,
on a croisé un pêcheur sans feux.
En pleine nuit,
les gendarmes font la tournée des parcs.
Leur mission, lutter contre le vol
des huîtres en cette période de fêtes.
On peut avoir des vols tout au long de l'année
mais c'est vrai que sur cette période là,
C'est quand même particulièrement sensible.
D'où votre présence sur l'eau ?
Présence sur l'eau accrue en novembre et en
décembre pour essayer de prévenir tous ces vols.
Pour le major Gazengel et ses hommes,
la nuit va être longue.
Les gendarmes de la brigade nautique
d'Arcachon poursuivent leur mission,
Au milieu des parcs du bassin.
Chaque année, surtout à l'approche de Noël,
Plus de trois tonnes d'huîtres sont volées.
On a un bateau qui remonte,
on va contrôler de l'autre côté.
Le major ne va pas tomber sur un voleur,
Mais sur une victime qui vient
de se faire voler ses huîtres.
Bonjour Madame ****.
Voilà, c'est ça. Je suis
allée relever le rang,
qui a été touché.
Et vous, vous pensez que c'était ?
Hier soir, on a fait la marée pareil.
Il n'y a que mardi soir qu'on n'a pas pu
la faire sinon on les a fait toute la semaine.
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé exactement ?
Simplement, j'avais rempli
un parc d'huîtres,
Qui avait été préalablement trié,
qui était en affinage et qui était complet.
Quand je suis venue à ma dernière marée,
c'est à dire ce matin,
J'ai retrouvé un trou dans les rangs.
C'est pas massif, mais c'est
vraiment très vexant,
Et c'est un fléau parce que ça
représente beaucoup de travail en amont,
Et c'est juste au moment où on va commencer
à récolter du fric sur le travail,
Qu'on se fait voler...
son bien.
C'est très perturbant.
Après, je ne sais pas si
ça mènera à grand chose,
Et on ne peut pas accuser n'importe qui.
Non mais je vous appelle demain.
C'est un peu l'angoisse de la personne
qui rentre chez elle et qui a été cambriolée.
C'est sûr que,
comme elle vous l'explique,
c'est frustrant et vexant.
Mais il y a aussi la frustration
de pourquoi moi ?
Veille de Noël, il est 5h du matin.
Les huîtres de Dominique vont
voyager dans toute la France.
C'est trois ans de travail qui partent ?
Trois ans de travail pour être
mangés en un quart d'heure.
Terminé ! Maintenant,
à eux de faire le travail.
L'hiver touche à sa fin,
Le bassin va pouvoir
retrouver ses lumières.
Sous le soleil du mois de mai,
les terrasses affichent de nouveau complet.
Dernier lieu du Cap Ferret, la nouvelle
cuisine extérieure de Laurent.
Les délais ont été respectés.
Ça fait un petit mois que
le lieu s'est ouvert.
Le beau temps, l'été qui arrive,
Et on est à peu près prêts.
Il manque quelques petits
éléments de déco.
L'idée est là, le concept est là.
Et au dessus, on en a fait des
logements pour le personnel.
Donc ça vient de se terminer d'ailleurs.
On a mis le dernier coup de
peinture la semaine dernière,
Et donc il y a déjà une
chambre qui est occupée,
Et le reste va suivre.
Une terrasse avec vue imprenable
sur la dune du Pilat.
Ils ne vont pas être mal là.
Là, oui je pense que ça
devrait bien se passer.
Je pense même peut-être que l'année
prochaine, je vais transformer ça en bureau,
Parce que moi, je suis en sous sol là-bas,
donc ce n'est pas normal.
Avant l'arrivée des grandes foules de l'été,
Dominique et sa femme Claude
profitent de leur jardin,
Ça sent bon ?
Dominique, c'est le bon
moment pour les tomates ?
C'est le bon moment pour les tomates.
On tarde toujours un peu parce
qu'on a peur des gelées.
Mais là, maintenant,
c'est vraiment le bon moment.
Et puis j'adore planter les tomates en plus !
Là, ce sont mes petits
coeurs de bœuf, que j'adore.
Je l'ai cassé en plus !
Le jardin, c'est ma détente.
Je fais un peu le vide ici.
C'est vrai que ma femme gueule
tout le temps parce que...
Tu es tout le temps avec ta cabane...
Mais c'est vrai que j'ai du mal
à débrancher de la cabane,
Ça me mine ça, c'est vrai.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi.
Il faudrait que j'arrête,
mais je ne peux pas.
Même ici, les huîtres ne sont jamais loin.
Pour Dominique, la retraite, ce n'est
visiblement pas pour demain.
À Gujan-Mestras, Grégory s'apprête à livrer
une pinasse qu'il vient de terminer.
Tradition oblige, le bateau va être
baptisé et béni par monsieur le curé.
L'heureuse propriétaire.
On va pouvoir commencer pour
ne pas vous mettre trop en retard.
- Est-ce que vous avez un peu d'eau ?
- Oui, bien sûr.
J'ai trop béni de l'autre côté !
Je met la tenue.
C'est tout un cérémonial,
c'est très solennel.
Oui, c'est une bénédiction.
Bénir, ça veut dire dire du bien.
Donc on le fait au nom de l'Église,
et c'est vrai que c'est
un moment assez important.
Vous en faites souvent ?
Alors ça m'arrive de temps en temps.
C'est vrai que, malgré tout, les constructions
de Pinasse, ça reste quelque chose de rare.
Donc c'est vrai que je suis content
que les maisons ici quand ils arrivent,
Ou sur le bassin quand ils ont ce désir là,
de faire appel à l'église pour vivre ce moment,
parce que c'est un vrai moment de joie.
Allez, on va y aller.
- Tout est prêt Gregory ?
- Presque.
C'est une naissance, on est sur
le même principe de réalisation,
Donc c'est important,
ça fait partie de nos cultures.
Et je vais maintenant bénir cette pinasse.
Que l'intercession de Notre-Dame
d'Arcachon, étoile de la mer,
Secours des marins,
Patronne des gens de la mer,
Viennent et reposent
sur celles auxquelles maintenant,
Nous allons donner son prénom.
Je vous invite...
Ayla.
Que Dieu bénisse maintenant
celle qui porte le nom d'Ayla.
Au nom du père et du Fils
et du Saint-Esprit.
Merci beaucoup.
On va pouvoir assister à ce moment
particulier de la mise à l'eau.
Il faut vraiment la faire prendre de loin.
Non, venez, c'est vous, c'est pas moi.
Il faut vraiment la jeter
et il faut fermer les yeux.
Quel dommage !
Très contente et émue.
Le cérémonial, le côté solennel justement.
Oui, j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait très bien parlé.
Ça m'a touché ce qu'il a dit.
La marraine !
Je vais tomber, moi.
Il y a les enfants,
ils vont vous tenir la main.
Ça valait le coup d'attendre.
Il faut acheter un grand drapeau ?
Oui, c'est pour ça que je l'ai mis.
Ainsi se termine une année
sur le bassin d'Arcachon.
De l'été au printemps,
Des couleurs, des lumières,
de belles rencontres.
Quatre jolies saisons passées dans cet
endroit unique en France.